foreign
everybody and welcome to the press
conference on the results of the donors
conference for the people in Tokyo and
Syria with President Wonderland and
prime minister Christensen I'm going to
give the floor to president on the line
with no further Ado for introductory
remarks president thank you very much
and good afternoon prime minister
christason and I
hosted today indeed the donors
conference for the people in turkey and
Syria following the devastating
earthquake I'm very happy to announce
that the International Community showed
today strong solidarity and I want to
thank all the donors for their generous
pledges and contributions
we all know that the scale of the
devastation is staggering more than 49
000 people lost their lives thousands
are still missing Millions lost their
homes
I would like to express once more my
heartfelt condolences for the lives lost
and wish a full recovery to those who
were injured
now the results
team Europe pledged today
3.3 billion euros for the people in
turkey and Syria
and in total
with the contribution of the
International Community we raised seven
billion euros for the people in turkey
and Syria
this pledge includes 1.1 billion Euro
from the European commission and 500
million euro from the European
investment bank backed by the EU budget
I think this is a very strong signal 7
billion by the International Community
the European Union has been by the
victims of the earthquake from day one
on of this tragedy
our search and rescue teams reached
gaziantep and the region barely a few
hours after the first earthquake
our humanitarian support started flowing
in within days
just like we were rapidly by the side of
the people affected with emergency
support we are now by the side for
recovery and reconstruction
not only with money
but also with know-how
we are ready to work with Tokyo on
rebuilding sustainably
we're ready to share our expertise and
experience on building seismic resistant
houses
schools and hospitals that the European
Union and tafkier have designed and
built together
in the last years have withstood the
terrible earthquake
and we are also ready to work together
to build environmentally friendly houses
to reduce energy use
and the impact on the climate
my last final point is on Surya
we have provided significant
humanitarian support to the people of
Syria
as soon as the earthquake struck
and today the European commission
pledged additional 108 million euro for
humanitarian assistance and early
recovery
all together
in this donors conference we managed to
raise with our partners
950 million euros for the people in
Syria this is just the first step this
is very important
because on the 14th and 15th of June
we will host here in Brussels the
seventh conference on the future of
Syria and the region
and the aim of this conference will be
both to focus on International
engagement for the political solution of
the conflict but also
to generate additional pledges of
humanitarian and early recovery support
for Syria
in conclusion today was a good day for
the international solidarity
we have shown to the people of turkey
and Syria that we are supporting those
in need but we know that there's a lot
of work ahead of us and this is the
beginning of a process thank you
thank you president prime minister the
floor is yours thank you so much thanks
I think today's meeting had one
important goal to turn
our words of condolences in solidarity
to into real action
and provide a strong efficient
coordinated response to help the people
affected by this devastating earthquakes
like I've said before this is a disaster
of historic proportions
the first earthquake had a magnitude of
7.8 on the Richter Scale the worst in
the region in a hundred years
over 50 000 people have lost their lives
so more than 10 million people are
directed affected of the earthquake
the material damage
is huge in Turkey alone at least 230
000 buildings have been destroyed and
around 3 million people have been forced
to leave their homes
Europe and countries across the world
were quick in sending immediate search
and rescue teams and immediate relief
following the catastrophe a clear sign
of solidarity
the willingness to help the affected
communities has been strong
in my home country Sweden the
catastrophe came very close
as very many swedes have family ties to
the affected regions and relatives
living there
the initial and fast response is now
being followed by new solid support for
humanitarian relief recovery
Rehabilitation and reconstruction
and we are pleased to see that our goal
for today's meeting has been achieved
we will see substantial new support for
the people of turkey and the people of
Syria this is a long-term commitment and
a broad range of actors will play
crucial roles in the work ahead of us
Civil Society organizations the U.N
family
humanitarian actors as well as
International Financial Institute
institutions and not least the business
community
for the Swedish presidency we are
grateful for the very good cooperation
with the Commission in arranging today's
conference
and very impressed by the substantial
results today but also very humbled by
the very important work ahead of us
thank you so much thank you thank you
prime minister I will now open the floor
for a few questions from the journalists
present in the room and perhaps those
connected remotely first David go ahead
let's see if I can get this to work yep
David bowati from Swedish
can I use this instead
hello
okay
David bowati from Swedish television a
question in Swedish for our prime
minister if I may
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
thank you very much second question in
the middle please the gentleman there
ah thank you thank you for the Flora
Turkish news agency
my question is to Madam president uh
like in many countries we have the
saying that goes every cloud as a silver
lining do you think that this disaster
could lead to a new chapter or
a progress in Turkish EU relations
this is a very important step in the the
EU turkey relationship but I'm also
deeply convinced that if it would be the
other way around and we would have a
terrible earthquake for example the
European Union I know we could rely on
our Turkish friends to help us so people
in need need solidarity and this is
therefore
something which the European Union does
because we are convinced that it is our
duty to show solidarity and to help as
much as possible but of course what is
also important we can work very closely
together for example to make sure that
the Reconstruction
goes fast that there's a change on the
ground so this will intensify of course
the work that we're doing together
between the European Union and turkey
and thus tighten the bonds
thank you I will now take for the sake
of fairness a question from homogeneous
connected remotely and that will be
becher hoping that it works
yes we can you be sure you can now ask
your question
I'm
teams
no
thank you very much for your
question what we're doing our work is
constantly in line with UN resolution
2254. it is very important here not only
every donor like as for example is
responsible for their own pledge and how
we use it
but it is very clear that here are only
contributions in line with these
guidelines
that are counted in the final pledge so
to make it very clear the European Union
does not work
but we always support people in need and
our humanitarian Aid that is the Syrian
support is neutral it is impartial and
it is independent
very important is also that it is
channeled by a humanitarian Partners
under the strict International
conditions we all know
for instance no interference from the
regime and full compliance with EU
sanctions
so bottom line people in need lead help
but there are international agreements
on how to deliver this help as efficient
as possible
thank you very much president and prime
minister this brings to an end the Press
Point uh with the president and the
Prime Minister but please stay because
we are following with a supplementary
press conference with commissioner
varghelli a minister for sale and
Minister Chava shoglu who can answer
more of your questions thank you
thank you